my whole life always wonder what my  birth family was like open it my mama  had six babies at the same time  [Music]  maybe beautiful Hey  [Music]  baby Peters in the hospital not every  day that a long-lost family member  appears at a thin air donated kidney who  said what why you got to take my kidney  why don't you take what it is don't look  at me cuz I sniffed way too much laptop  cleaner and I pop tamale yesterday I  wasn't moly  [Music]  just gotta find the rest of them  I always wanted to do that these past  few days have been the greatest of my  life model since we hit the road  together I've done things I've only seen  intelligent  [Music]  how you fight  you  you